years ago I had a really big crush on
you and so I had this whole plan like
all week I was like I was like he's
gonna ask me out he's totally gonna ask
me at home and then like later in the
week I was like I'm gonna ask him out I
mean he said like surely because like I
created the romance in my head because
I'm delusional okay and so I was like so
I was like okay you know what I'm doing
it I'm doing it and so I'm in the I'm
getting a costume fitting and I had this
whole plan I was gonna ask you out and I
was like and I started thank God I
talked to the Wardrobe lady about it and
I was like I think I'm gonna
yourself I'm gonna give him my number
and she was like honey he's engaged
hahaha